all right Mr Meadow I sent into
the State Department of Corrections on
each of the murder indictments
in the murder of your wife Maggie
murdaugh
a sentence you for the term of the rest
of your natural life
for the murder of Paul
murdaugh
whom you probably love so much
I sentenced you to prison
for murdering him
for the rest of your natural life
those sentences will run consecutive
under the statute involving possession
of a weapon doing a violent crime there
is no sentence
where life a life sentence is imposed on
other indictments
that is the sentence of the court and
you are remanded to the State Department
of Corrections
and officers May
carry forth on the opposition
that was Judge Clifton Newman in the
courtroom in Colleton South Carolina
delivering the sentence uh to uh Mr
Murdoch saying that he uh delivers two
consecutive life sentences and in doing
so uh reference the fact that he
committed murder of his wife and son who
he probably loved so much saying that he
will now spend the rest of his natural
life in the state's Correction Facility